ich dachte es mal auf was hast du dir
geholt die hat nicht nötig haben
hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge der today show immer noch
zusammen mit dem guten alten dena und
heute haben wir zu gast den sparkurs
gedacht sparkasse in der house sparkasse
jena haben wir geredet
wir hatten die vision jetzt wo ist der
stimmt nie da hinten war unser sport
zwei grad aus der map raus
ich dachte der krieg der trainer
reporter gesagt das sind zusammen oder
bist du das spot-media haben das letzte
mal nicht fertig bekommen aber die
kommen dann einfach irgend noch mal
irgendwann noch mal zu gast und das
packen noch theoretisch die sachen von
topshop media nehmen oder denen sie
können sie einfach irgendwas daraus
können ich weiß nicht was hier hatten
der umlage selber auch nicht ist aber da
komme ich gerne daran dies zu also kann
sich öffnen
immerhin so skyrim leichen plündern hier
sind es jedoch nicht unique ist ich kann
nicht öffnen
ehrlich sagen ich bau dir mal gucken was
passiert sagt leider geht nicht kann
euch ab und ich habe keine richtige ich
kann ich noch blöcke zerstörbaren nichts
denn das ist das was wir wollen hier ist
es einfach mal
es war das erste mal der ist das schon
okay oder
jetzt gehts dem thema thema thema der
reden über ein thema brauche ich muss
jetzt mal gucken was war das war
bestimmt tollem design tunnelsystem
gebaut habt ja das war darauf hab ich da
gesehen und nach dem out unterwelt
mensch ich hätte fast [ __ ] gesagt
aber zumindest unterwelt mensch naja
erstes thema was wir direkt ansprechen
könnten was in der ersten folge einer
ersten nein das war nicht in ersten
folge was wir suchen und direkten thema
raus was ihr uns geschrieben habe
nämlich die erste minecraft welt wie war
es mit dem thema eure erste minecraft
welt oder wir zu minecraft gefunden hat
wie war es also für euch also sei der
erste und mit skype auf beschäftigt
machen die erste minecraft welt habe ich
mir zur beta 1.5 erstellt bisher hat mir
viel gebaut als deinen ic wagen eine
nachhaltig
ich hab ich ne menge gebaut aber dann
habe ich die welt irgendwann verloren
ich weiß nicht warum ich würde so gerne
wieder spielen ich würd 10 euro dafür
bezahlt dass sie diese welt immer mal
wieder sehen könnte weil war ich kann
mich noch ein paar sachen erinnern und
das wandern zu die guten alten zeiten
und ich habe meine mit noch ist die welt
dies gleich schon übrig geblieben bis
jetzt noch vor
geil alter ich beneide dich alle genau
die ersten anfänge meister ruhig meinte
kramer ist neben sarah kreuz und bands
haus eingerichtet hat ich war damit hat
die es ein kleines haus und dann habe
ich das immer in die höhe gebaut dann
habe ich den kleinen wald gebaut dann
habe ich so einfluss drum herum gebaut
und zu alles so voll idyllisch und dann
irgendwann habe ich meinen dass wir
damit auch auf den laptop und dann hatte
der virus und dann na ja alle dich damit
zum arzt gegangen zum computer arzt und
dann weil er meinte dann wir müssen die
minecraft importieren
ja das ist leider jeder faktor der das
alles erst alles zu über kochen bringt
so also ich weiß nicht genau was die
frage jetzt bezogen war einfach nur und
auftritte sowie erst noch direkt am
spawn hab ich noch mein allererstes haus
gebaut aber selbst wenn ich irgendwie
stimmen sollte ohne bachelor immer schön
am spot- und ladegewicht weggelaufen
euro fällig in seinem sport bin ja
früher ich ja noch in der alpha weil
wenn der schnee weggeräumt ist aber nur
schnee und ich dachte es kommt
irgendwann anders und ich bin ewig
gefahr ewig gelaufen bin ich also
laurich mal dass man immer da konnte man
auch am anfang des wortes da war das
noch nicht so mit dem bett oder so ja
das war kacke in der alpha ich habe
ralph angefangen hat ihren gefangen der
beta 1.3 weder 150 die kinder gleich
aber trotzdem hat früher mit dem letzten
angefangen als ich das weiß ich auch
noch
es kann sein das ist auch sehr genau so
von wem war das thema das thema war
voller bevor ich es vergesse zusagen von
heidi metro tv
oder so ähnlich aber es mag was machten
hier gerade über livestream ich habe die
komplette ich brauche es mehr holz im
kopf hat der guardian spitzer als
wirkliche also immerhin der akte
bekommen von uns ist mein spanisch
vergessen sie dabei kabine raus nehmen
können oder die halbe irgendwie gar
nichts
diesen einverleiben wir alles inventar
gepackt haupt nix mehr
trotzdem sind die weiter als ich es geht
nicht drei auf einmal gut hardy am
zutritt gebaut jacke gut ist natürlich
unfair ceo von kultur ihr soll ich mal
da gab es von creative modding das
wesentlich schneller muss man alles noch
sondern sich zusammensuchen klick klack
der theorie ist das hier ist das hier
ist das gesetz nicht so auf die schöne
häuser wir wollen mehr produktivität
dass man sich die zeit einteilt da
wollen wir so den letzten jahren ein
bisschen helfen
das ist der einst der einzigen der
einzige grund ist dass man eine
zeitliche spanne hat für dieses let's
play und dann zum beispiel vier folgen
wenn ein gast kommt und man muss in
dieser zeit ein haus schaffen und damit
wollen wir einfach die let's play unter
zeitdruck setzen
ok vorher lässt du uns denn raus oder
was oder mich nicht raus nicht fertig
braten nachher einig also noch nicht
einfach disconnect machen
nee das kann sich aber trotz geht es
geht nicht du kannst nicht das korrekte
ach da mache ich ein feature dass
manager auf prozesse abschließen ehe das
haben wir auch mit einem ort mit drin
die etwas lan kabel raus sowieso schluss
fehlte deswegen alles nicht jetzt ja den
us katze bei dir unterm tisch und hält
das da drin so ähnlich haben
der kleine raus weil der knipser schon
abgebrochen
herrlich feldmann fast raus also ich
habe ja w lan kabel wenn ich noch mal
drüber gestolpert und a ha ha ha so
witzige start wo willst du dich
eigentlich einbauen
das werde ich mir gleich wenn ich genug
ressourcen hab kann weilchen dauern
ja ich glaube ich auch dass ich brauch
erst mal wieder steine abbrechen brauch
in der regel wenn ich was brauche ich
von ressourcen her ungefähr das ja keine
ahnung 33 taten fache eines normalen
menschen
weil ich immer so viel verpasst aber
warum nehme weil ich einfach so viel
variation mit reinbringen und nicht so
langweilig bau also ein haus einen ein
material sondern ein haus 10 materialien
da sind den und ich eine komplette
gegenteil eigentlich auch nicht ich
wollte diesmal ist anders machen aber
ich wollte dachte immer ein bisschen
einfacher dann habe ich vielleicht auch
noch zwei drei folgen ein bisschen schon
so ein dach oder so aber noch kein
dunkles holz irgendwo als erster so ich
hab noch keinen doch ich glaube ich habe
mein studium gesehen
ich weiß nicht warum als suchen in
meiner suchen der bild sogar schon
hingehen das erste mal zerreißen
komplett vorher mal jetzt noch drei
externen dann hab ich jetzt mal holz ich
musste mir grade erst mal kabel stone
holt hätte nie mehr was zu essen kann es
sein doch drei rotoren dass sein
bekannter sein
ich habe zwei schnitzel ruhe schnitzel
damit ich denken kann
du musst dir auch wieder bäume hin
pflanzen frank rost macht alles kaputt
auch zum beispiel setzlinge dahin so die
setzt dahin
sonst landen wir dich oder so würde laut
doch nicht so der minister auf
gefährlichem eine stop over nicht laufen
lassen ich glaube ich mache das ohne
erneute begrüßung und nehmen einfach
durch den kauf oder wie macht ihr das
aufnehmen so wie jeder an einem durchweg
also macht ja so dass wir nach 50
minuten war sie hatten heute ist
durchweg durchweg aufnehmen
okay wie jeder gerne ich machen und
füßen
hallo ich doppelt irgendwie bisschen bei
mir wahrlich hallo hier bei mir ist
alles noch mal okay gut wenn jetzt auch
alles normal
na ja alles gut alles gut und so sage
jetzt hier ein paar sachen dann gehe ich
hatte meine kraft in boston cloud m
lange ich dachte das wäre nur eine von
damals kassenbox nicht mehr
ja gut okay es wird nacht dann lasst
gleich einfach losgehen
einfach war und dann bringen wir am
besten nehmen wir uns ein paar bisschen
weizen mit damit wir tiere erholen
können ich dachte mein haus was hast du
dir geholt hat mich wohl ich hab mich
wirklich ob sie zeitlich mit der nahrung
du hast hast du geholt den wassers dem
spiel heraus ich habe nicht gut weil ich
nicht wusste auch so hinkel nicht längst
erholt
ich gucke jetzt ich hab echt nichts
geholt
ich hab nichts gut wenn du dich noch mal
lag dann bin ich tot sich nicht lustig
und verliere ich sie haben sieben
experten
verlieren wir dann ich habe gar kein xt
level weil du mich jetzt mal getötet hat
nein habe ich nicht ich hab dich nicht
gekühlt
ich hab dich nicht gekillt traurig nicht
höher auf das ding in something is an
die angibt denen dein haus ist aber
bisher auch sehr schön wieder auf mich
zu töten
wo jetzt noch kohle was ist denn das
backhaus wieder mein haus meine tastatur
hängt ich komme nicht weiter das sagen
wir alle wenn sie es alleine ins haus
gelaufen
wir wollen wir wollen einfach meinem
haus bleiben auch wenn jemand rein im
icc war ihm überhaupt noch genau wie
sich aus den betten und so kenne ich
auch sagen deswegen wollte ich ja
hierher locken
wir haben das sogar meinen rabatten im
gar nichts wir haben doch wer keine
schafe gefunden
das ist richtig krass ich hatte schaffen
schildert
ich habe den leuten scharfe schere ja
aber ich will keine schafe na dann
müssen wir halt jetzt direkt in der
nacht los sondern sehr gut angenommen
und zuerst ein schwert oder so bevor es
losgeht
das ist eigentlich an organisieren hier
ist ein crafting box ach so yao boden
das wäre dann ein drittes paket hast du
zwei venen weggenommen
keine ahnung hat einen hingesetzt dann
habe ich den weg genommen damals dachte
er irgendwie weg dann hat er sich neu
gemacht jetzt macht er sich eine dritte
ja so eine umweltverschmutzung von ihrem
bann von holz sowie in israel hier eine
video neulich hat zwei kräften boxen vor
sich stehen direkt vor sie vor der nase
macht noch ein drittel der in der
örtlichen presse ev dvs web kentucky um
luca ich hätte schon wir müssen locker
steiniger erkenntnisse fasst erpressen
da ist seit deutsch-amerikanischer
youtuber der vorgehen redstone schaltung
macht ist er echt amerikanische genuss
ich glaube also englisch
im ressort geht ich hab im schnee bio ja
wo bist du single auf welche richtung ja
ich dachte wert hinter mir
touristen wir haben hier noch am haus
rum
der kommt man zu koch medias aus dann
treffen wir uns da okay jetzt einfach
bei f die richtung sein können auf 112 3
oder 4
das sind oder 11 15 30 wieder zu
kompliziert kommt einfach zu
ich sehe dich bleibt stehen da muss
blickt der schaden bekommt der beste und
ich habe kein schaden bekommt doch der
zahn bekommen bei mir ich habe volles
leben
das sieht auch eine aufnahme ein
bisschen runter gerannt reicht kann das
sein wo der ist nun wasser explodiert
von daher dachte ich mir aber kommt es
nicht mehr darauf
dabei liegen jetzt hier ich war jung
einfach bei in richtung pop shop medias
haus zu dass lukas ein zombie weil die
sau gekillt die wollte ich bitten
ich sehe eure namen aufleuchten in der
ferne in der dunkelheit kommentar ich
den schlimmen der meere die einen dass
ich die augen aufleuchten der
veränderung kite jetzt das medium weil
ich so nah
ich brauche das für meinen linken für
mein haus ich weiß wenn ich noch nicht
und brauche ich noch mein haus mein
bisschen unter der erde bauen es gibt ja
auch nicht so schöne konstruktion unter
der erde
das hätte man auch anders
irgendwas anderes werde ich mit der
einfachen lassen wollte
aber schon ist mitdenken mitdenken und
so verbunden müssen also das ist jetzt
als skelett ich will endlich einen bogen
von dem skelett bekommen habe ich noch
nie
die haben nur power +1 netz oder börner
aber immerhin einen bogen
dabei muss man nicht selber treffen
ja ich weiß nicht warum gehe oder her
bogen sehr willig zu kräften
ja sagt experte es geht darum bogen zu
kraft was hat das jetzt mit rätseln oder
so zu tun
gar nix aber trotzdem
ist das schwer falsch wäre somit klicken
und so ich wusste damit wirklich nicht
wie ein bogen geht
ich habe mich ja immer vertan mit den
strings und den stack sogar meine kraft
texture pack beim crafting fenster mit
tritt wie das geht
ihr habt mich dass ich gerne weil die
leute nicht wussten wie es geht weil ich
habe das immer so gemacht dass man dass
ich überrascht dass ich immer die
strings eingebogen angeordnet habe und
ja gerade das funktioniert nicht
abdecken ocholt sonst würde ich jetzt
wieder gehen
ja ich habe lange genug ich mache gerade
erst mal ein bisschen platz zum crafting
box mal noch drei extra beim erstmal ein
paar bäume problem ist nirgendwo spinnen
sind natürlich denn irgendwelche treiber
töten oder hinter seiner ich habe könnte
wollte mich aus fragen bis aufs knie
oder was irgendwie jetzt eher allgemein
von den themen her wie ein paar fragen
ob man sie fragen was haben wir immer
irgendwas attraktiv werden haben wir
themen wie man gerne fragen wir wollen
hier keine frage runde machen
so schrecklich die letzten reihen kommen
dann stelle ich meine wenn dich die
leute kennen dich das war nix vorher ist
das bak auf phoenix west ist voll
schlimm und ich werde mal spar kopf
genannt es gibt ohne scheiß gefragt ob
sparkurs mein vorname phoenix mein
nachname